baby turtles being sold on the strip not
in the store literally on the strip 80
of them were rescued from an illegal
business as victoria saha reports they
are now at the animal foundation getting
prepped for adoption
the animal foundation is usually filled
with barks or meows
but they've been busy taking care of
creatures that hardly make a peep as an
open intake shelter we see a bunch of
crazy stuff
but getting 80 baby turtles at one time
is definitely a little bit more rare
those turtles were rescued from an
illegal business on the strip tasha
crabtree with the animal foundation says
they were found in a suitcase you guys
want munchies
we did notice that there were some
deviations in the smoothness to their
shell which could indicate that they've
been malnourished the animal foundation
let the public know about these baby
turtles on monday and by tuesday morning
18 of these little guys have already
been adopted but by tuesday night all
are gone i met shelby nebaker and her
sister who planned on adopting one we
have two in our backyard already and so
if we can get another one especially
baby because they're so cute that'd be
really cool these turtles can live more
than 13 years victoria zaha live local
now